-Today is my final day
before a haircut
and our last show
in our Captain's quarters
and it's bittersweet
because there's so much,
so much, we didn't get to.
For example,
I had hoped to introduce
a talking Jon Hamm painting
that didn't wanna be here.
-I don't like this bit.
I don't wanna do it.
-I wanted to do a bit
about checking in
with my friend Ethan Hawke,
who I'd put in charge
of exterminating the wasps
in my attic.
-Seth, th-they've
taken over, man!
They've learned how
to use tools!
It's a --
It's a [bleep] nightmare!
-And I wanted Amy Schumer
to be my first, and only,
Captain's quarters
in-studio guest.
-You ran out of time?
-I thought your people
would've told you.
-No. I've been sitting here
for an hour and a half.
I-I --
-Oh, I --
-Can I just plug --
Can I plug my show really quick?
-We really are short on time.
-Okay. Should I go?
-That'd be great.
Thank you, Amy.
And thank -- I'm so sorry.
This is awful.
-Okay.
-And I just need you to, um,
just keep 15 feet.
-15?
-Yeah.
-I think it's six.
-I think you can make it
right over top of that thing.
Thank you, Amy.
-Well, thank you.
-I'm so sorry about this.
-Me too.
I really wish I'd known.
I took a ferry, you know.
I took a ferry here.
-You -- Oh.
-I was told I could promote
my -- my show.
-Boy, oh, boy.
-"Inside Amy Schumer"?
-No!
-Oh.
-The cooking show!
And just --
but maybe in the city,
I could talk about my show?
-That'd be great.
We just didn't have the time.
It's also the last day
with all our friends behind me
and I'm happy to report
that everyone who went
on this journey with us
found what they were
looking for.
-I got a new voice!
-I got cleaned.
-Yeah, I got my own podcast
and, if you could tweet
about it or whatnot,
my people think that
could be very helpful.
-And it turned out
the ghost lobster
who long tormented
the Sea Captain
only wanted companionship
and, once he discovered that,
the Sea Captain
not only forgave him,
he offered him the job
of first mate on his ship.
-Thank you, Sea Captain.
-Thank you, friend.
-And the Sea Captain, well,
he maybe got
the best gift of all.
-I got to participate
in a long, psychotic bit
that would have eaten [bleep]
in front of a live audience.
-Speaking of psychos...
-Final summer segue!
-...yet another of the
president's close confidantes,
his former campaign manager
and chief strategist,
was arrested today
for a wild scam
that captures so much
of what's rotten about Trumpism.
For more on this,
it's time for "A Closer Look."
[ Suspenseful theme plays ]
I don't need to tell you guys
that everything's bad
and good news is very rare,
but when it does come along,
why not gorge ourselves on it?
Even when it comes later
in the day,
causing you to rip up
a finished "Closer Look"
and start from scratch.
Hey, you guys remember
Steve Bannon,
the white nationalist/
giant pimple
who ran Trump's campaign;
then worked in his White House
and helped engineers such odious
policies as the Muslim ban
and who publicly defended
the horrific
family separation policy;
often wore two shirts,
when one would've sufficed?
You know, the dude who had
a crazy-person whiteboard
in his office,
with policies scrawled on it,
like "Suspend immigration
from terror-prone regions,
Implement new extreme
vetting techniques,
and Suspend the
Syrian Refugee Program."
I'm shocked it didn't
also include
"Brunch with Slenderman"
and "kill the Batman."
You know, Steve Bannon,
the gentleman
who currently looks
like a guy selling
exotic reptiles
on the Venice Beach Boardwalk.
Steve Bannon wasn't born.
He just burst out of someone's
chest, Quatto-style.
He looks like
a "Where are you now"
about the face-melt skeleton
from "Raiders of the Lost Ark."
Look at this.
It's like if the Cryptkeeper
spent a month
in a tanning booth.
Well, now that we've piled on,
we can move on.
Oh! Wait. I forgot.
One more thing.
You guys,
[ Laughing ] he got arrested.
-News just coming out from the
Southern District of New York,
saying Steve Bannon
and three other men
have been arrested
and indicted and charged,
in relation to their role
in a nonprofit organization
called We Build the Wall.
It's a crowdfunding organization
that, the FDNY says,
has raised about $25 million
for wall-related funding.
What the indictment here
is alleging
is that Bannon and his others
were skimming some
of the proceeds
from that fundraising
for themselves,
even though they had
suggested publicly
that this was a volunteer
organization
and they were not
taking salaries.
-Steve Bannon, through
a nonprofit organization
under his control --
nonprofit one,
as it's referred to here
in the document --
received over $1 million
from We Build the Wall,
at least some of which,
they say,
Bannon used to cover hundreds
of thousands of dollars
in his own personal expenses.
-You know what, baby?
It's been a brutal six months,
so I'm gonna mainline
some schadenfreude.
Line that up on a mirror
and give me a dollar bill
to snort it with.
[ Snorts ]
Whoo!
Seriously, did prosecutors know
this was our last summer show
in the Captain's quarters?
Because this is
a fantastic parting gift.
That's right,
Steve Bannon was arrested
for allegedly skimming
$1 million from a scam charity
that claimed to be raising money
to build
the Southern border wall.
This is the perfect
encapsulation of the Trump era.
From beginning to end,
the wall was a nonstop scam.
Trump scammed his supporters
by telling them Mexico
would pay for it.
Then, we ended up paying for it.
Then, this baked-potato
Fabio over here
said he'd raise money for it.
Then, he scammed everyone again
by allegedly skimming
money from it.
It's a Russian nesting doll
of fraud.
I can't wait until Bannon raises
money for his legal defense fund
and we find out he lost it
all at the racetrack.
"Sir, please,
we'd love you to leave.
You're scaring the horses."
And, as NBC's Pete Williams
reported today,
it's pretty obvious this thing
was a scam from the jump.
-According
to the court documents,
this We Build the Wall thing
came and flamed out quickly.
According
to the court documents,
the founder of it,
this man, Brian Kolfage,
said that he would not take
any of the money,
that it was entirely
a volunteer effort,
but it's said he did take
a lot of money.
And, as for Steve Bannon,
it says
he formed a nonprofit
organization that he controlled.
It received about $1 million
from this crowdfunding effort,
some of which,
the Justice Department says,
he used to cover --
and I'm quoting here now --
"hundreds of thousands
of dollars
in Bannon's personal expenses."
The court documents
basically say
that this thing
was pretty suspect
almost from the beginning.
-I mean, of course it was.
A crowdsourced fundraiser
to build a [bleep] wall
in the middle of the desert?
The only way it could've been
a more obvious scam is
if they offered free boner pills
with every donation.
The thing was one rung
below those companies
that claim to name
a star after you.
"Oh, yeah, that one up there
is -- that's, uh, Dan.
That will be 5,000 bucks.
Cash only."
The details of this arrest
are just absolutely incredible.
Every little tidbit
is better than the last.
For example, according to CNN,
Bannon was arrested
on a boat Thursday off the
eastern coast of Connecticut
by federal agents,
along with officials
from the United States
Postal Inspection Service.
He got arrested on a boat
by the postal service.
The postal service has a navy?!
Please tell me it's just a mail
truck with a giant cannon.
Nothin' is more fun
than imagining
a bunch of postal service
inspectors,
in their short shorts,
boarding a yacht
and arresting Steve Bannon
in a dramatic
high seas sting operation,
swingin' down on a rope,
carrying letter openers
like swords.
How has there never been
a "CSI: Post Office"?
Something tells me David Caruso
would definitely
come back for that.
[ As Caine ]
Looks like this package
has been
returned to sender.
-♪ Yeah! ♪
-That's how he held
his hands, right,
after he put on his glasses,
very delicately, like this?
Like he was still holdin' 'em.
Seriously, think
about how perfect this is.
The same public agency Trump is
currently trying to destroy,
one of the most cherished
public institutions in America,
arrested his former
campaign manager
for allegedly skimming money
from a fundraiser
for their scam border wall,
two days after we found out
Trump's previous
campaign manager
colluded with Russian
intelligence.
It's like the end
of the summer TV season
and they're wrappin' up
all the story arcs at once.
This really is such a perfect
encapsulation of Trumpism.
It's all a giant grift.
Bannon was gettin' rich,
and so was Trump.
The dude's constantly
at his own properties.
Lobbyists and foreign officials
stay at his hotels
to curry favor.
His sons are goin'
around the world,
drummin' up new business.
They're all just
fattenin' their wallets
and dolin' out cash
to their rich buddies
while they take health insurance
and unemployment benefits away
from millions of Americans
who are suffering
and out of work.
Trump was asked this afternoon
about Bannon's arrest
and all he could muster
was this...
-I think it's a very sad thing
for Mr. Bannon.
I think it's, uh...
surprising.
-Oh, really?
You're surprised?
Trump's probably just surprised
Bannon had the idea before him.
[ As Trump ]
Jewelry and a boat?
How come I don't have a boat?
My hair would look great
flapping in the sea breeze!
Trump then seemed to offer
some kind words for Bannon.
-I do think it's a sad event.
And again, Steve has had
a great career at Goldman Sachs.
-Oh, Goldman Sachs.
Well, that's a surprise.
Those guys have never done
anything untoward.
That's like saying, "He was
in the mob?! I'm shocked!
He had such a great career
in sanitation.
Why would he just
throw that away?"
Seriously, at this point,
Trump has enough criminals
around him for a [bleep]
"Ocean's Eleven" remake.
Of course, that movie
would end ten minutes
after Trump
gets the team together
and one of them
livestreams it on Facebook.
[ As Trump ]
Okay, that's the
top secret plan.
Lev, I can't help but notice
you're making
a front-facing video right now
and it seems like,
based on the beeps that are
comin' outta your phone,
you're gettin' live
feedback on it."
These guys just cycle
through one scam after another.
Remember, even before he became
president, thanks to not one,
but two criminal conspiracies
on his behalf,
then got impeached for trying
to orchestrate another one,
he settled a fraud lawsuit
over Trump University.
His charity was dissolved
for misusing funds.
He was even sued
over a scam vitamin company
and, now, he's doing it
all over again.
-President Trump says
the White House is looking
into a new, unproven
coronavirus treatment,
called oleandrin.
It's made from the
oleander plant.
It's extremely toxic.
It's been used in coronavirus
trials involving monkeys,
but it's been never
tested on people.
-I've heard of it, yes.
It is something that people
are talking about very strongly.
We'll look at it.
We're looking at a lot
of different things.
-Okay, first of all,
anytime you ask Trump
a question about anything,
he's gonna respond
by saying,
"We're looking at it."
He'll never admit he doesn't
know what you're talkin' about.
It's why he will never fall
for a prank question.
If you ask Trump,
"Sir, does smell
like updog in here?"
He would say...
[ As Trump ]
People are saying it
and we're looking at it
very strongly.
We're looking at updog.
We're looking at downdog.
We're looking at all
of the dog directions.
You know, we have the best
updog in the world.
A lotta people --
A lotta people are saying it.
You're hearing it more
and more under Trump.
Very little --
No one was talking about updog
under Obama!
[ Clears throat ]
I made myself choke,
doing a Trump impression.
So, now, Trump is touting
a plant extract
to cure coronavirus.
Honestly,
it's only a matter of time
before he shows up
on the White House lawn
with some crystals
and a dreamcatcher.
The guy will fall for literally
any old-person scam.
I'm convinced the only way we'll
get him out of the White House
is by selling him
a reverse mortgage
and waiting for him to default.
[ As Trump ]
Damn it!
I knew you'd betray me, Magnum!
Not only is oleandrin
not a COVID cure,
it's a deadly plant poison.
So, now, he's suggested
ingesting bleach,
hydroxychloroquine,
and a deadly plant poison.
[ As Trump ]
Even better, combine
those three in a bowl
with some Sudafed
and battery acid.
Dunk your bare ass in it.
You should be totally cured.
Now, it will not
surprise you to learn
Trump did not get this idea
from a doctor
or one of his actual medical
experts that works for him.
He got it from yet another one
of his many snake oil salesmen
he surrounds himself with.
-Mike Lindell is the CEO
and founder of MyPillow.
He is also the chair
of President Trump's
reelection campaign
in Minnesota.
He reportedly helped arrange
an Oval Office meeting
with the president in July
about oleandrin.
Lindell tells CNN the president
was enthusiastic.
-Just for our viewers,
you have no medical background.
You're not a scientist.
A guy called you in April,
said he had this product.
You are now on the board
and going to make money
from the sale of this product.
-No. No, no, no.
-The reason he reached
out to you is
because you have
the ear of the president,
so he gets a meeting
with the president
and you stand
to make money from this.
-That's your narrative.
-How do you sleep at night?
-Anderson,
that's your narrative.
Why would I do this?
Ask yourself why I would
-Money.
-ruin my reputation
if I didn't believe
-You don't have
-in this product.
-a great reputation.
You don't have a great
reputation.
-Oh, really?
-Yeah! MyPillow guy thinks he
has a great reputation.
Though, when people know ya
as the MyPillow guy,
instead of your actual name,
you don't have
a great reputation.
You're just one rung
above Keyboard Cat.
No one knew the cat's name,
unless it was Keyboard Cat.
I don't think it was.
I mean, this whole thing
is like the Question Mark guy
demanding a table at the Palm
and screaming,
"Don't you know who I am?!"
So the MyPillow guy
has the ear of the president
and is pushing him to advertise
a deadly plant toxin
as a cure for coronavirus.
This guy, I mean,
he's just dead set
on puttin' people to sleep,
one way or another.
We are living inside
a [bleep] 3:00 am infomercial.
We can't give you ventilators
or unemployment benefits,
but every American
will be getting
a Shake Weight and a Slanket.
What all this proves is that the
country is currently being ruled
by a deranged
political coalition
that's incapable of governing
and is interested only
in enriching himself
at the expense of voters.
And, now, they've left
the country in ruins
while they're lining
their own pockets.
A thousand Americans
are dying a day,
tens of millions are
out of work,
and many more suffering,
and the president's cronies
are cashing in
with boats and jewelries,
and hawking scam plant toxins.
Donald Trump badly botched
the response to a deadly plague
that has left
170,000 Americans dead
and caused the worst
economic crash
since the Great Depression.
We have outbreaks in schools.
Parents don't know what
to do about child care.
Veterans aren't getting
their prescriptions in the mail.
Everything
from the school system
to the post office is broken.
The post office.
We had to come together
to save the post office!
It's like something
out of a '80s teen comedy.
"Come on, guys!
If we win Battle of the Bands,
we can use the money
to save the post office!
Whoa!
Is it just me?
Can that werewolf play guitar?"
Trump is not unique
and he's not an anomaly.
Bannon and the MyPillow guy
and all the Republicans
enabling him prove that.
They're all Trump.
And the only way
out of this mess is
a thorough national rejection
of their toxic ideology.
It won't save anything,
but it is a start.
And, if that doesn't work,
I guess we can just rely
on the postal service
to take him down.
After all, if today's news
is any indication, it's...
-Something that people are
talking about very strongly.
-This has been
"A Closer Look."
♪♪
Tonight ends a run of 68
out-of-studio shows
that began in March,
shows we did from hallways,
garages, attics, and, of course,
here in the Captain's quarters,
aka, my in-laws' house.
Our remote shows started bumpy
and, while they never got
totally smooth,
I do think
they got a little better.
And, for that, I wanna thank,
among other people, Matt Parker.
I don't know Matt,
but when this first started,
he made a YouTube video
with tips
on how late night hosts could
better produce shows from home,
and I reached out to him and he
was an incredible resource.
He was so helpful
and it was a real reminder
of how amazing a place
the Internet can be
when good people use it
with kindness.
And I do want to thank everybody
who watched this show,
everyone who engaged with us,
everyone who voted
in our Sea Captain polls,
because I have not had a single
person in the room with me
for any of these shows,
but I have never once
felt alone.
And, in these awful,
stressful times,
that was such
an incredible gift.
I want to thank my crew
in New York,
who figured this out;
my writing staff,
who didn't miss a beat.
I want to thank my many friends
who recorded voice-overs for me.
And, Sea Captain,
if it's not too much to ask,
could you take us out
with a song?
-Sure thing, Seth.
-♪ When I find myself ♪
♪ In times of trouble ♪
-Oh, sorry, Sea Captain.
We can't --
We can't clear that song.
-Oh, right, right.
Well, how about a little
sea shanty, then?
-Great.
[ Birds squawking ]
-♪ The moon is full,
the sea is calm ♪
♪ We're ready to depart ♪
♪ No way to know the ending ♪
♪ When you're standing
at the start ♪
♪ And for all those
lads and lasses ♪
♪ Waving at the pier ♪
♪ Let this be the last song ♪
♪ That they this night
shall listen to ♪
♪ Oh, goodbye, goodbye ♪
♪ I'll see you
on the other side ♪
♪ For what goes out
comes in again ♪
♪ Just like the rising tide ♪
♪ When life is tough
and the water's rough ♪
♪ Have a good friend
at your side ♪
-♪ Goodbye ♪
-Aah!
♪ I'll see you
on the other side ♪
♪ Oh, this past half year
has been severe ♪
♪ On that we all agree ♪
♪ But have no doubt
we'll make it out ♪
♪ If I have you here with me ♪
♪ So batten down
the hatches, boys ♪
♪ And pull your mask on tight ♪
♪ I promise
there'll be mornin' ♪
♪ If we make it
through the night, oh ♪
-♪ Goodbye ♪
-♪ See you on the other side ♪
-♪ For what goes out
comes in again ♪
♪ Just like the rising tide ♪
♪ It's not the road
I woulda chose ♪
♪ But I sure enjoyed the ride ♪
-[ Laughing ]
-♪ Goodbye, goodbye ♪
♪ I'll see you
on the other side ♪
♪ Oh, goodbye ♪
♪ Goodbye ♪
♪ I'll see you on the other ♪
♪ Side! ♪
[ Birds squawking ]
♪ Side ♪
-Stay safe.
-Wash your hands.
-Wear a mask.
-All:
We love you.
[ Shuffling ]
-Daddy, it's time to go.
-It's time to go?
But, Axel.
-What?
-Where does that door lead?
-I don't know.
-That's all I need to know.
Let's go, boys.
-Why?
-Just, we're gonna go.
-No, not another time!
We said it --
-Don't give away how many
times we've done this.
-Yes!
-[ Laughing ]
-[ Claps ]